I used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time it's for protection from what's
coming
all right down it's next no matter how
fast you are
I am not to be compared to you knowing
our rugs are past
crying your vegetable coming and mine
just caught up to me been a long time
don't
[Music]
so we're up against a master thief
high-performance driver
who is he
[Music]
Jacob is Tom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than down stronger than
time
but could you kill him because I'm ready
if you are
as if I no no no that's that's not in
for us hey they got a magnet plane hold
on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you think there's no
surprise
nice Clubhouse
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my fast and furious 9
trailer video they dropped one for the
Super Bowl and there's so much to talk
about in this is so crazy each moment
crazier than the last
and they brought Han back it's crazy
hashtag justice for Han so we'll break
it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a bunch more
big Superbowl trailers dropping this
weekend - apparently John Cena is
playing the villain of this movie and
he's revealed to be Dom's long-lost
brother who he calls little brother
so John Cena in this equation is
apparently the little one even though
your head is spinning at the thought
that John Cena is somehow the brother of
DOM I'm assuming their foster brothers
or Step Brothers or somehow they just
became a family before Dom's current
family that he has now but he's also
supposed to be a master thief and an
expert car man they bring back Charlize
Theron's tech villain from Fast &
Furious 8 they introduce a much older
version of baby Brian
Dom's son with Elena from the previous
movies who of course they named after
Paul Walker's character Brian in his
honor
they even bring back Helen Mirren's
character letting you know this takes
place after the events of Hobson Shaw
because in that movie she was in prison
right at the end of it I guess spoiler
warning for Hobson Shaw if you care
about that kind of stuff Jason Statham's
character and his sister break her out
she says okay why don't we get out of
here so presumably right after that
moment they busted her out of prison and
that's where they show up in this
trailer I loved watching her in these
movies the movies themselves are so
ridiculous but she knows exactly what
kind of movie she's in so they're
probably just paying her a giant took a
change and just letting her have
whatever kind of fun she wants to have
from the trailer itself it just seems
like Charlize Theron characters trying
to take down the crew using Dom's
brother to do that because these movies
are all about family they keep repeating
that word over and over again they the
whole ideas that Dom's family is his
weak point the whole reason why he
seemingly turned on the crew and fast
state was because she was blackmailing
him with Elena in his son we didn't find
out about that till about midway through
the film and if you haven't watched it
in a while there's actually a scene from
this where he's fighting John Cena which
is taken directly out of the Black Widow
trailer it's literally the exact same
fight shot so when you see John Cena and
Dom stealing each other's guns it's
literally the exact same scene of Black
Widow fighting the yell in a Bulova
Black Widow what they still
each other's guns they do it a couple
times back and forth maybe this as is
typically the plot of these movies John
Cena's character and Dom will probably
eventually put aside their differences
and take down Charlize Theron's scare
achter in a much bigger way than they
did during fast ate what I'm really
hoping to see though is that they find a
reason for them at the end of this movie
to drive a car into space because that
would be hilarious like the whole idea
is how do you get crazier with each Fast
and Furious movie like this one seems a
little bit crazier than the last one and
so on and so forth but that means that
number 10 has to be even crazier and
what's the most ridiculous thing you
could think for them to try and do and
that is literally drive a car into space
in fact when you see this bit here that
they do with the rocket car you have a
Fiero with a rocket strapped to it this
is actually another Tokyo Drift
character they'll explain in a second so
you think it's a joke that they would
try to take this franchise into space
with the last movie but we'll find out
in a couple years I guess since these
movies are about being as big and crazy
as possible they know exactly who their
audience is and they know how to deliver
to it so we'll do top 5 WTF moments just
see how crazy we can get number 5 is the
twist reveal that John Cena is Dom's
long-lost brother hello brother as they
just beat the crap out of each other
number four is them flipping the giant
convoy truck tank like truck in the
middle of the city end-over-end you even
had that long slow-mo shot of them
watching it like holy crap number three
is Charlize Theron's skater using the
magnets on her jet to catch John Cena's
Mustang gt500 mid-air right after he
drives off a cliff somehow this is not
the craziest thing that they do in the
trailer because number two then Dom
tries to one-up his craziness driving
his charger right off the cliff hooking
it to part of the rope bridge Indiana
Jones shout out and using it to swing
the car onto the other cliff using his
nos Busters you would only see something
like this in a fast and furious movie
suspension of disbelief bad props to
these films for making this scene even a
little bit plausible and obviously
number one WTF han is back hashtag
justice for Han his line of dialogue
about the clubhouse is also a reference
to Tokyo Drift the movie where he
seemingly died
remember when they got to future movies
and they wanted to bring him back they
had to explain that those movies were
taking place earlier in the timeline and
it just got really crazy trying to force
these movies to make sense when clearly
they're not meant to make sense so I
think the idea here is that they'll say
that he's alive in present day because
this movie definitely takes place after
the events of fast 8 because little baby
Brian is a little bit older so they'll
just have to find a way to explain how
he didn't die in this seeming bigoted
car explosion the end of Tokyo Drift the
whole reason they hated Jason Statham's
character when he entered the franchise
is because he was the one who was
revealed to have seemingly killed Han at
the end of Tokyo Drift but I guess
because they've been redeeming him over
the past couple of movies turning him
into an antihero and he's been helping
them like he'd probably help him during
this movie at some point they'll have
some way of explaining that he didn't
really kill Han back then and it was all
part of some bigger plan it's way easier
to say something like that like Oh
surprise reveal I didn't kill him I was
actually helping him because of this
larger plan than to try and make the
timeline make sense if Hana was
supposedly dead there's probably a bunch
of other Tokyo Drift Easter eggs during
the movie that just didn't make it into
the trailer
but Jason Tobin's character here the one
with the Fiero rocket ship is also a
character from Tokyo Drift and he only
just peeks around the corner of the
frame here but this is Lucas Black's
character also from Tokyo Drift
so it's cool to see him come back to the
franchise - I'm assuming they'll make a
lot of references to that because part
of this movie looks like it takes place
in Japan like these fight sequences so
that may be where Han winds up coming
back into the story but everyone let me
know in the comments what are your
favorite craziest moments in this
trailer does remember that that's what
these movies are about just being as
crazy as possible and just badass car
stunts I was working on a new Marvel
Avengers video when this trailer posted
I'm about halfway done with that so that
New Avengers video should post in a
couple hours later tonight as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see that when I post it there's
gonna be a really big Black Widow Super
Bowl trailer later this weekend - so of
course I'll do a video for that and any
other really big Super Bowl trailers
that drop everyone click here for my
brand new Marvel Eternals teaser
breakdown and click here for my brand
new Doctor Strange to x-men video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome just as for Han
[Music]
hey guys